bonjour merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
sur place expliquez-nous que s'est il
passé
à quelle heure les faits se sont
déroulés tout d'abord bonjour
comme vous voyez je m'excuse mama voix
tremble encore qu'on est encore sous le
solde sous le choc
justement je n'étais pas très loin de
l'explosion et on a entendu une petite
déflagration on a eu l'impression que
c'était un mur du son ou d'évasion ou
autre qui peut se passer malheureusement
couramment au liban et a été suivi
quelques secondes après par une très
très forte explosion ou gt toutes les
vitres ont volé en éclats toutes les
sirènes et c'est la panique totale sur
les rues évidemment le réseau de
téléphone mobile et tout d'un coup est
surchargé donc on ne peut même plus
appeler pour s'assurer de la famille etc
et ça nous a rappelé les plus tristes
moments de la guerre du liban je peux
vous dire que c'est un peu beaucoup trop
pour ce pour ce pauvre peuple pour ce
pauvre pays
pour l'instant on le rappelle on ignore
exactement les circonstances de cette
déflagration cette déflagration de ces
deux explosions qui ont retenti vous en
parlais à l'instant selon les
informations préliminaires de médias
locaux il s'agirait
d'un incident au port de beyrouth quel
type d'entreprise sont situés dans ce
secteur tout d'abord fessés au port donc
sur le port il n'y a pas vraiment d
entreprise des photos qu'on a en tout
cas une des vidéos que j'ai envoyée à
votre production
c'est exactement sur le port donc c'est
des containers sans doute qui ont été
touchés par cette érosion et on imagine
que les images tournent en boucle
tournent en boucle sur les télévisions
libanaises
qu'est ce qu'on dit sur les antennes
quelle est l'analyse des experts qui
sont sans doute entendu en ce moment
regardez les informations mais encore
une fois rien n'est confirmé qu'on a sur
le terrain c'est que ça ça peut être où
un raid ou bien un raid aérien ou bien
des tories qui sont ils un bateau c'est
ce qu'on est en train d'écouter et ce
que je trouve tout à fait logique parce
que c'est c'est ce bruit qu'on a entendu
ce qu'on a vécu à tout dans toute cette
impression donc ça peut être un incident
spécifique et un bombardement je dirais
très ciblé d'un ou deux roues de
plusieurs containers et peut-être même
d'un bateau de d'habitude de sur le port
c'est donc et ça qu'on voit alors c'est
ce qu'on écoute donc ça peut être une de
ces trois solutions
le doute ce soit une explosion parce que
c'est le périmètre du port est sécurisé
donc c'est difficile de faire entrer en
cas d'explosion bon ce qu'on peut
enlever c'est que ce n'a pas été contre
des personnes parce que le premier point
qui nous a passé à l'esprit c'est que ça
peut être une explosion qui était
dirigée contre quelqu'un ou des des
personnes politiques aujourd'hui je
pense qu on doute mais il ya beaucoup de
blessés
les hôpitaux commencent à demander du
sens là je vous écoute et je reçois des
messages énormément de blessés même
d'aider des personnes encore jusqu'à
maintenant sous les décombres et a dit
beaucoup de blessés aux alentours par
des vitres donc les hôpitaux de la
région commencent à recevoir énormément
de blessés et font des appels pour pour
donner du sens et autres et les équipes
de secours sont partout tout autour